it's time to hand out the awards
i well i first off i just lost you can
you hear me all right because i can't
hear you i hear you're fine okay good
there it goes all right good it glitched
out for a second i got really scared
there okay here we go my first one i i'm
gonna try not to hit the patriots
seahawks or cowboys game right mike just
because we talked about them i we
haven't hit this one yet that's the
chris how many years have you been doing
this right how many years we've been
doing three yeah we try we try to plow
new ground thank you okay let's talk
about things we haven't talked about yet
the mcgenius award for the sean mcvay
award because
right now sean mcvay i mean he is
mcgenius you know for what he's done the
first two weeks
i look at him and go the rams are 2-0
and i know we always give the head coach
a lot of credit but he deserves even
more credit just for his offense what
he's doing right now
the pace in which they're playing
and the way they went in to philadelphia
yesterday where really dominated the
football game fumbled a punt return late
in the first half that let kind of
philadelphia back in the game but then
kind of found their way to put their
foot back on their throat and suffocate
them once again i mean mcvay and just
the formula in which he's got on the
offensive side of the ball right now
with all the bootlegs the play actions
the screens
staying tough to the run game and
everything like that how can you not be
impressed with the rams after two weeks
just whooping up on two nfc easter
opponents yeah one of the things i was
most wrong about going into this season
was that the rams were in decline and i
looked at all the departures and they
pushed outweighed phillips and todd
gurley that was a mistake brandon cooks
gets dumped
dante fowler gone via free agency and
and you know not that he was a huge
piece but it just felt like they were
into
felt like they were taking a step back
and maybe they did but they've taken a
step forward very very quickly so i
agree with you on that and also let's
remember this
they've only played teams from the nfc
east yep maybe when they play some other
teams like i don't know the teams in
their own division that could change the
first one for me and i want to get this
out of the way now because it doesn't
directly relate to the games but it does
this is the cone of silence award and it
goes to the national football league for
two things for two things first of all
somehow
some way
the executive vp of officiating al
riveron was not in the building last
week the guy who's in charge of replay
review was recovering from covet 19 and
somehow
none of the teams were told oh by the
way the guy who's chiefly responsible
for replay review isn't here today he's
he's off this week even if you don't
want to get into the reasons why the
idea that no one knew that al riveron
was out for week one is astounding to me
that they kept it quiet
and uh and i'm surprised they even said
anything a week later yeah
you've escaped it's the equivalent of
escaping prison and looking back and
getting shot just let it go why why let
anyone know that that that he wasn't
there just keep moving forward so that
amazed me and secondly this one is more
substantive and i think problematic it
was reported yesterday by nfl media
and i think this was based on direct
quotes from walt anderson who's involved
in supervising officials now that the
officials have been instructed to focus
only on clear and obvious fouls this
year
okay that's fine good hey perfect fans
don't want to see a bunch of flags great
people been complaining about that for
years let's not have ticky tac fouls
excellent perfect well done bravo
but don't you think you should tell the
teams about it like i don't know at some
point before the season begins we always
talk about points of emphasis and new
rules it goes into coaching how do you
coach your team up and get them ready if
you don't know there's been a dramatic
change in the focus on when a flag is
going to be thrown i mean i'd like to
think that any coach worth the salt is
going to take the time to explain to his
players hey you know what maybe we can
get away with a little you know a little
grab maybe that's why they didn't do it
well but but they should then why say it
now right why say it in week two well
maybe because they got complaints
through the league and through players
and coaches i mean i think there was a
lot of games last week where we walked
away with man they let them play there
wasn't many flags thrown so maybe there
was complaints from coaches about that
and that's why they let it out i don't
know
well or but look i i don't know i know
what you're but you know they're
committed i think they're committed this
year
to saying that all is well with the
officiating even when it's not that was
the aftermath of the michael gallup opi
call i mean there it was right it was
right it was right and and they're not
finding mike mccarthy for saying it was
wrong why because then it's another news
cycle of us pointing out that maybe it
wasn't right and i think that with all
the other challenges they're facing the
last thing they want is a boiling pot of
officiating concerns so let's just let's
just keep it on the back burner but
my broader point is if you are going to
make that kind of a dramatic change and
the focus of when a flag is going to
come out you need to tell the teams asap
so they can factor that in to how they
coach their players within the confines
of the rules it's that simple if the
trigger changes for when a flag is going
to come out that's fair and appropriate
information for the teams to have and
now hey at least they know
a couple of weeks in but they should
have known before the season yeah all
right chris i hear you all right
night of the living dead award i mean
the never say die award you know where
i'm going here i mean the kansas city
chiefs it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable
get my homes down by 10 and you know
what you're guaranteed to lose i mean
that's where we're at in the career
that's where we are he's undefeated i
believe one down by 10 points or more
that's it six straight wins that it's
just amazing too
and again yesterday
just just not able to get anything going
but their ability to step on the gas at
the moment they need it and just always
deliver is mind-boggling it really is
you know coming up with big plays
whether it's his bomb you know sprinting
out to the right for a touchdown to
tyree kill the kicker
kicking three 58-yard field goals in a
row before finally one of them counted i
mean just amazing that way uh
and and even the defense coming up with
a big play now it was a stupid play and
i want to hit on that too justin herbert
was phenomenal for the los angeles
chargers and i feel bad for tyrod taylor
i really do that's a tough situation but
man i mean that looked like uh you know
it's the baker mayfield story part two
like tyrod gets hurt here comes the guy
that was the top one of the top picks he
comes in whoa he looks good i don't know
if you're gonna ever get back in there
again and herbert other than that that
interception up 17-9 throws a dumb
interception on second and third he
could have ran for a first down he was
really played a clean game but the focus
is again i want to go back to the chiefs
and just ice water in the veins i've
never seen anything like it nothing
seems to phase them and i never see
nervousness in patrick mahomes eyes i
just i never see it i i thought maybe i
was singing at the end of the super bowl
last year but i'm he just he continues
to amaze me uh and and he's the flip
side of the falcons yeah i mean it is
you're right if you blow enough leads
you start thinking this is the way it
goes if you keep coming back from double
digit deficits you believe this is the
way it goes and what happens is the
opponents start believing it too sure
you know when when tony romo had that
reputation for always making a big
mistake in a big spot and that lasted
for a while until he reversed it i
remember heinz ward telling me there was
a game the steelers had with the cowboys
where you you just could sense it on the
sideline here it comes here it comes and
i think that if you have enough guys
who are feeling that vibe you know how
that the momentum swings go and just the
sense you get in a stadium with the
chiefs now the sense is
no lead is safe and it's just a matter
of time before they do whatever it is
they're going to do to come back and get
you yeah pretty much what's scary about
the chiefs is
they haven't even played great
football even at the end of last year to
now and they're still can't be beat and
i think that's where the rest of
football should be really scared because
i just
again i think if they get all cylinders
go and all systems go here just watch
out because i still think they're kind
of figuring it out their way on both
sides of the ball a little bit and
that's what's scary for the rest of the
nfl
so basically you're saying patrick
mahomes is a zombie yeah pretty much
he's uh you can't kill him he never dies
yeah right
uh okay uh next one for me this is the
off-broadway award uh you know how like
you know that it's it's always the
lesser show
yeah yeah baby you know you know how
that works yeah kyler murray is the star
of the off broadway production this year
yeah without question right nothing he
can do is going to register with anyone
look and it's in part because of their
schedule i have their schedule pulled up
here somewhere here it is i mean they've
got they've got the lions this week no
one's going to pay attention to
cardinals lions they've got the panthers
the next week no one's gonna pay
attention to cardinals panthers they've
got the jets for crying out loud the
week after that who cares it's not until
week six that the show goes to broadway
when they play the cowboys in prime time
on monday night football and then the
next week they have the seahawks right
but the starting time chris
it's 405 pm eastern it's regional
broadcast it's not even in the 4 25 p.m
window
and it's going to potentially be
undefeated cardinals against undefeated
seahawks in the two most exciting
quarterbacks in 2020 in football and the
thing about colin murray you know you
look at russell wilson's play and his
numbers and it's like wow
kyle murray's numbers don't match his
play so it's not even something that
casual fans are going to notice if
they're looking at the stats i mean his
passer rating is actually down this year
over what it was last year but he is
nothing short of spectacular and it's
amazing to me and it's going to keep
them from being considered for mvp it
already feels like they're just going to
hand it to russell wilson this year not
that yeah they're not handling them
anything right right right right but but
it's like it's the lifetime achievement
award oh and by the way you're earning
it but kyla murray's not gonna have a
chance not with russell wilson around
and not with all these games that are
played in these windows that nobody's
caring about the game they're not seeing
the game they're against opponents that
aren't compelling but he does get two
cracks at the seahawks coming up after
that monday night debut against the
cowboy well i mean
i mean you're right we need to talk
about him here regardless and
if they start to go if they go to 3-0
and 4-0
and 5-0 they'll start he'll start to get
the attention he deserves but you're
right it's going to take longer than it
probably will in most cities or with
most quarterbacks that are in that
situation uh whatever that may be but
he's a special talent i mean it's the
second week in a row we saw
you know mighty mouse or whatever you
want to call them the front four
kryptonite
two of the best front fours we've seen
in football just get
basically
not be a part of the football game don't
get to establish their dominance because
of kyler murray i mean he did it to the
49ers last week and then yesterday with
washington defensive lines the story of
week one washington their ability to get
after carson wentz yesterday it's not a
story at all i mean there's nothing to
it and that's because of him and you're
right mike the stats don't tell you the
story here and the value he has to his
football team and everything about that
unfortunately in the nfl more times than
not you gotta have like a great year
before everybody starts to
take notice and then take you legitimate
and it seems like it's setting up that
way for kylie murray but man is he he's
fun to watch um here's the big
difference he's running the ball a lot
more last year he had 544
rushing yards in 16 games this year he's
got 158 in two games three touchdowns in
two games he had four all of last year
rushing he's on pace and it's only two
games but
it's 79 yards a game it's pace for 1264
which would be the single season
quarterback record breaking the record
set last year by lamar jackson but
that's the key he's running more this
year which makes him more fun to watch
more spectacular and more impactful yeah
he seems to be just being more
comfortable he hasn't he has the right
like feel of when to leave the pocket
when to you know when to hang in there
when to maybe just stay back there and
buy a little time to extend it he's got
he's he's very mature and wise for a
young football player amazed and him and
cliff kingsbury they deserve a lot of
credit all right um
i'm giving uh
the dead award okay as in d-e-a-d dead
to your minnesota vikings see ya see you
next year
we'll see you in the 2012 i'm putting a
fork in them i don't know how we can
look at them right now and sit there and
just go oh they're going to rebound now
i know they got a few good football
players definitely and mike zimmer and
they got pride and they're not going to
go down easy but i don't think
i don't based on yesterday well you're
right yesterday was a sorry look and all
around i don't even know where to start
but yes i mean i think i could sit here
legitimately after week two and go
minnesota vikings playoffs no chance
this year none
i mean they're a team that has really
lost their way here offensively yeah
you're seeing no stefan diggs maybe
stefanski was a little better than we
gave him credit for there calling plays
on the offensive side of the ball and
the turnover on the defensive side is
just it's too much to overcome for them
to still be dominant so that was an ugly
look yesterday and they were severely
outplayed and kirk cousins was reeling
and and i i feel he's not good don't get
me wrong right now but
from what i saw on film last week and
what i see this week too
you know just on tv yesterday it's not
like he's missing plays it's not like
there's people wide open it's like he's
playing horrible you know they got
issues all together on their offensive
side of the ball
yeah i agree with you completely one of
my favorite stats of the day stefan
diggs the former vikings receiver now
with the bills had more receiving yards
than the vikings had total passing yards
yikes yesterday wow and chris you know
my theory on this i know i hate there's
this theory to be proven right but
they beat the saints in a playoff game
that could have gone either way the wolf
start handing out financial rewards
because of it to kirk cousins to mike
zimmer to rick spielman and eventually
the dalvin cook and this whole pandemic
thing you know this panda it's
there are all sorts of things you can
rely on at some point as crutches and
excuses in football usually it's
injuries and that's why the patriots are
the kings of no excuses for injuries
they expect the next man up to perform
at the same level as the guy he's
replacing even though that guy was at a
lower level for a reason no excuses
we're not going to get we're not going
to get down in the mouth we're not going
to feel sorry for ourselves we're not
going to say well wait till next year i
feel like the pandemic the fact that the
vikings can't have fans there and can't
have a true home field advantage
something mike zimmer has publicly
complained about
i think that when you throw in
the financial security that's been given
to all those key figures they're on
scholarship this year this year doesn't
matter this isn't real this is 2020 and
if we go 2 and 14 so be it and i just i
even though no one's going to say it and
they're probably going to get pissed off
if i keep saying it enough and maybe i'm
trying i don't know that i'm trying to
i'm just stating facts i don't care at
this point this is about
what is happening in front of our eyes
and it is a team that that got sad i
don't know they do i don't know where
what where's the fire where's the fight
where's the where's
there's no attitude or edge to the where
is it yeah where is it i don't know i
don't know what to say but you're right
some sort of magic or continuity with
the team have certainly been lost and
they're gonna have to find their way or
yeah they're in trouble i mean they they
really my advice was at the time after
they got after they got humbled by the
49ers don't give anyone an extension
don't do it make them all play you did
you set it on tv for their next contract
i'm here
quote unquote good problem to have if
you go to the super bowl or get closer
to the super bowl or have a special
season with all these guys chasing their
contract you give them a contract when
they got bounced from the round of eight
with a performance where it was over by
the well it was really the third quarter
when it was over close at halftime but
once the 49ers flipped to run run run
the vikings got blown off the field and
you reward guys for that
and and it just it's i'm sorry i'm sorry
but hey there's got to be accountability
even in a year that feels like there
should be no accountability because the
world's turned upside down there's
plenty of other teams kicking ass and
the vikings are going to be the team
that's on the wrong side of the ass
kicking more often than not this year
yeah it does seem that way and they got
a tough little schedule ahead of them
too i mean they got the titans the
seahawks coming up here shortly the
texans who are not nothing's gonna be
easy you're right i mean you don't you
can't look at the your minnesota vikings
right now look at them and go stop it
all right what else you got another one
no i'm throwing it back to you do you
got one or nothing
i got ranting about my own thing you
know i i got a couple of others go ahead
i got a couple others here's one i got a
sean taylor award i mentioned this last
night in the tapings that we did in the
third quarter but i want to make sure
that our audience this morning
appreciates it the hit that justin
herbert put on the chiefs linebacker oh
my reminded me of the sean taylor hit on
brian moorman i've never seen a
quarterback hit someone like that
he's the one who's supposed to be
getting the welcome to the nfl moment
not delivering the welcome to the nfl
moment what what
i i don't even know what player that was
yet uh that he that ran into him and
concuss themselves and i don't mean to
laugh because i know that's not that's
not like a a
laughing matter but herbert that's the
thing i mean we talked about the chiefs
a little bit first off you see the size
of that sucker out there he's he looks
like cam newton almost on his uniform i
mean he really does he's impressive
looking he can throw the ball with the
ease and we saw his speed and ability to
make plays with his legs and man
collision on the right sideline he
barely lowers his head
and whoever that is that comes in to hit
him is coming in like just 100 miles per
hour but i think he was probably
surprised with how big of a man this guy
is he really is and i don't know mike
we'll see where that goes i know uh
anthony lynn said tyrod taylor's gonna
be the starter when back healthy and
things but i have a feeling that that's
gonna be one of those things where
the owner and the gm
and everybody's gonna watch the film of
the game today and go wait why why are
we going to put tyrod taylor back in we
can play now that we know yeah go ahead
we know we know the full story on tyrod
taylor it could be that anthony lynn
didn't want to disrespect tyrod sometime
when he's at the hospital he had chest
pains before the game he was on the
injury report friday with a rib problem
and he fully participated in practice
but in pre-game warm-ups he started
developing chest pains they took him to
the hospital i mean doesn't matter how
old you are you start having chest pains
it could be a sign you're having a heart
attack they take him to the hospital to
get checked out he was discharged last
night anthony lynn said after the game
repeatedly that when tyrod taylor is
healthy he will be the starter but look
and none of that's binding none of it's
how many times have we heard a coach say
something like that and later
circumstances change or
we're not quite sure what's wrong with
tyrod so he's not healthy so we're going
to keep playing justin herbert i got to
give this kid credit chris
assuming that the story is true and i
have no reason to disbelieve it this
guy's just minding his own business and
he finds out right before kickoff you're
playing like literally at least they're
lining up for the kickoff
while the game's happening you know
there's a chance on any given play you
get you get pulled onto the field that's
part of being a backup but to find out
right before the game starts you're the
guy holy crap and to respond the way he
did there's something there and and
there's going to be fan pressure to the
extent they have any fans uh and so
there may be no pressure at all in that
regard i said yesterday they're the only
team that actually gains an advantage by
not having fans in the stands because
there would have been a bunch of chiefs
fans there yesterday but yeah i think
that it was out of respect to tyrod
you're probably right that you're not
going to change starters there because
you can always say we went back and
looked at the film and we were blown
away by what we saw yeah exactly and we
made this draft pick for the future but
we can't deny the reality after seeing
how he performed against the chief's
defense the future is now it's very easy
if that's what they want to do yeah
he's got superstar talent mike he was
you know as you know my number two
quarterback coming out in the draft this
year
and
always from the very start said his
ceiling is higher than any quarterback
in the draft it's higher than joe burrow
he is physically special as far as the
things he can do on the football field
and we saw that a little yesterday made
the one rookie mistake but other than
that played really awesome and like you
said like an unbelievably uh tough
environment all right i mean you know we
always talk about like you know your
parents do they trust you with like the
you know the new hot rod the the luxury
car or whatever hey kid this is my car
you know
keys to the new car award i'm going you
know where i'm going josh allen i mean
i'm surprised it took you this yep i
couldn't help it i mean we've gone 23
minutes in the eight o'clock segment
here and we haven't talked about maybe
the guy who might be the mvp of football
other than russell wilson through two
weeks i mean josh allen again yesterday
forget the stats which are mind-boggling
and the way he playing right now is
mind-boggling the thing that jumps out
to me and i know we talked about it a
little last night
is
they're trusting him with the game and i
think that just says so so much to me in
so many ways because sean mcdermott he's
a defensive coach
he wants to control the game run the
ball play defense i'm sure it's not easy
for him to go with a guy like josh allen
who's got a little that brett favre
patrick mahomes gunslinger type attitude
in him but he has reigned it in this
year i mean
i
through two weeks and i didn't watch the
film of yesterday i i've only seen like
one miss one mistake as far as just like
oh why did you throw it there everything
has been good decisions accurate throws
big time throws down the down the field
and
up 24 to 20
with three minutes left
and have a second and nine and to call
an aggressive deep throw and he throws a
46-yard touchdown pass to john brad i
think that just said it all to me that's
where i went oh he's in the trust tree
he's in the circle of trust as robert de
niro said he's there because for them to
call that type of play and that moment
with the game and the balance and
everything like that i think that shows
you that they've trusted his work ethic
what he's seeing on the field and then
of course what he's how he's delivering
on the field as well
yeah i think you're right and uh you
know it's a shame russell wilson's doing
what he's doing or josh allen would be
getting some mvp buzz early on they keep
winning hey he's going to have two
head-to-head contests against cam newton
that's the way josh allen can get some
attention like russell wilson did
yesterday you show up big in that spot
against the patriots and cam newton
people are going to start taking notice
people took notice yesterday one more
before we go the what the hell is brett
favre doing here award what the hell was
brett favre doing at the tampa bay
buccaneers game wearing a tom brady
t-shirt and it's just a few days after
favre was on radio saying that bruce
arians is barking up the wrong tree by
calling out tom brady publicly i just
thought it was kind of a neat moment to
see uh somebody sent me the link and
yeah just jarring first of all seeing
anybody at the game at all and here's
brett favre with his tom brady in the
buccaneer logo the old
uh the old logo what do they call that
guy bucky the bruce bucco bruce
bucco bruce how did i how did i forget
that yeah he's got he's got a he's got
what what it did maybe he said tom he's
winking at you look at there it is
he didn't have the he didn't have the
knife in his mouth though he needs this
scabbard is it a scabbard that's a nice
mask by the way brett well uh oh well
yeah well and he's he's he's got enough
red on his face he's like bruce aryans
he's trying to match the uh face of
bucco but maybe tom invited him for
inviting him he's like hey get get
behind bruce aryans when we're on the
field heckle him tell him to shut up
stop heckling me as a quarterback i mean
it is it is i i thought that was weird
too i i really did but uh that's the
ultimate quote if that happened that's
the ultimate passive aggressive move by
tom brady the hall of fame quarterback
who
calls out bruce aryans for calling out
tom brady gets invited by tom brady to
come to the game and shows up in a tom
brady shirt and even though tom brady's
never gonna say it bothered him what
bruce arians did last week
there's a chance that all the evidence
we need
is what the hell is brett favre doing
here seriously and that tells us that at
some level that was tom brady's middle
finger to bruce arians at least i'd like
to think that it makes it more fun that
way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports